le quoi qu'il en coûte cher à emmanuel
macron ce n'est pas nouveau du moins
lorsqu'il est question de chouchouter le
gouvernement en effet elle dès qu'il
faut se montrer convaincant en vis-à-vis
des français il semblerait que
l'exécutif n'hésitent pas à dépenser
sans compter avec des sondages des
études ou encore des baromètres en tout
joueur à la clé nos confrères de
l'ops/oms mener une enquête minutieuse
et les sommes dépensées pour soigner
l'image de l'exécutif et mettre ses
actions en valeur donne le tournis le
budget du service d'information du
gouvernement le sig organes chapeauté
par matignon est en charge de toute
enquête d'opinion pour le gouvernement a
doublé pour la seule année 2000 20 c'est
simple 14 millions d'euros était prévu
28 ont été dépensés crise sanitaire
oblige la vie des français étaient
particulièrement scrutés notamment juste
avant et pendant le premier confinement
si bien que selon les calculs du
magazine un sondage a été commandé
toutes les quarante heures entre début
mars et fin
c'est une somme hors de proportion c'est
à se demander si les annonces faites
chaque semaine lors des conférences de
presse d'olivier véran n'était pas
autant dictée par les sondages que par
des considérations sanitaires
alors oui aux grands maux les grands
remèdes c'est comme ça que l'elysée a
justifié cette somme à dépenser mais bon
avec de telles sommes on se dit que le
coc vide a bon dos car ces dépenses ne
concerne pas que la crise sanitaire en
cours depuis 2010 cette aide est que
l'exécutif souhaite mettre en marche ses
réformes
on peut constater que les commandes de
sondages et d'études augmente
à titre d'exemple 20 études commandées
en deux mois par matignon pour la
réforme de la sncf en avril 2010 8,7 en
vingt jours pour la réforme des
retraites fin 2019
et vous vous en doutez tout cela n'est
pas gratuit
loin de là c'est d'autant plus onéreux
que les sondages d'opinion ne sont pas
les seuls outils utilisés pour prendre
le pouls des français en effet il faut
aussi compter sur la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux pour tout contrôler
entre guillemets le sig a signé des
contrats faramineux avec des sociétés
dont la vocation est d'analyser ces
échanges numériques publics
bin ibrahim et l'une d'elle depuis 2010
cette matinée
a signé pour environ 3,5 millions
d'euros de contrats avec cette
entreprise
voici pourquoi une telle somme il ya eu
un changement de paradigme avec les
réseaux sociaux l'agenda médiatique
maintenant il est aussi dicté par le bas
par des réseaux sociaux par des
mouvements d'opinion qui peuvent
intervenir par des régimes sociaux des
sites internet par des déclarations de
personnes qui sont beaucoup moins
institutionnel surtout je pense que
c'est surtout ça l'enjeu pour pour
emmanuel paris éviter ce phénomène gilet
jaune de bâton capacité de voir une
révolte du peuple se construire petit à
petit finalement pas être en capacité de
sentir que finalement la cette réforme
ne va pas passer
alors esprits et big brother es tu là
c'est un peu le ressenti quand on voit
tout cet argent dépensé pour scruter les
français ou du moins les comprendre
selon les termes officiels connaître
l'opinion c'est une chose nous
convaincre en est une autre et là aussi
le gouvernement met les bouchées doubles
le sig encore lui à conclure 2018 un
accord de quatre ans avec un grand nom
du secteur la société dentsu haggis
network montant du deal 300 millions
d'euros
la surveillance un coup mais c'est
visiblement nécessaire pour être au plus
proche des français
les termes du contrat englobe conseil en
stratégie média achat d espaces
publicitaires partenariat campagne
d'intérêt général et informations
gouvernementales cette dernière
expression peut faire tiquer et
s'apparenter à la promotion pour les
réformes envisagées par l'exécutif
emmanuel macron est un féru le sondage
et d'analysés qui on recommande
davantage que ses prédécesseurs
et enfin le troisième élément qui tel
celui qui doit nous inquiéter
l'interrogé le plus c est ce que
finalement c'est ils demandent c'est ses
commandes et ces contrats passés de
certaines sociétés elles sont faites
dans l'intérêt général
ou est-ce qu'elles sont aussi au
détriment du contribuable pour servir
les intérêts des manuels macro est
lamentable delà de la communication sur
ses intérêts port vous l'aurez compris
la communication à outrance est le fer
de lance de la politique d' emmanuel
macron et de son équipe vous
le mental sauf que sous ses aspects
démocratique on peut y voir une
stratégie bien plus calculer prendre le
pouls des français pour reprendre
l'expression du locataire de l'elysée en
déplacement cette semaine dans le lot ne
se passe pas dans nos campagnes mais
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
et si ce déplacement du locataire
l'elysée était perçu comme son entrée en
campagne en vue de 2022
elle cette dernière a peut-être eu lieu
bien neuf